JD what's going on with you in Rappaport
Michael Rapaport the actor I faced in
this past week in fantasy football and
you know how he is whatever he likes to
be very you know he tries it getting
there in your head a little bit Gary you
[ __ ] I got a secret weapon now I want to
take this [ __ ] Jason Kaplan okay I
want to zip tie him I want to [ __ ] them
and then I want to cook up wake up
[ __ ]
wake up will Murray hit him with two hi
I'm gonna ruin him and I'm gonna [ __ ]
his face I'm saying like I'm gonna [ __ ]
his face during fantasy football so then
he started calling you at home or was he
calling you here I'm gonna pick it up
does it bother you that he calls no cuz
I know he's trying to do just like I'm
gonna [ __ ] you in the ass you know he
gets crazy I try to say stuff backed all
the Nagus all weirded out what do you
mean like I say sounds like are you
ready [ __ ] or whatever I go yeah yeah
bend me over or something like that and
he doesn't want his proposal accepted he
wants you to be grossed out let me hear
this JD this is Michael Rapaport Sunday
morning you know what that means right
it's time for [ __ ] I've been [ __ ]
every single person in this league i
lapped fault
big fat Jason Kaplan I beat him so bad I
ran around the track [ __ ] him from
behind
mmm kept going that's called lap [ __ ]
really into fantasy football then he
gets annoyed with the JD that he hasn't
called him back Jelena KD takes just
dick
have you cut your [ __ ] hair yet call
me the [ __ ] back you're not that [ __ ]
important have you ever thought about
getting in the stringent you know I mean
like for oily skin you [ __ ] and it goes
up man he spends halls Sunday dude why
would you call him back call me back so
I can give you skin care tip like a
stringent
with demean you are you kind of honored
in a way JD when you think about like
kind of but this is like a guy who's
been in major films calling you and
wants to [ __ ] you in your ass higher
learning then he was great there he was
yeah and now I have a you know annoy you
meet every Sunday yeah I mean it's kind
of cool like yeah you see our Mike
Rappaport I got the skills I got the
class and when those guys lose their
butts are bruised or when I [ __ ] them up
in math